I can't even distinguish what's real and
was faking the hands bro yeah they can't
they got hands yet yeah everyone's got
like nine fingers and it's all long and
alien like the Pope's necklace only had
one side
[Music]
we all know that AI has been getting
crazy there's a III that's very good
there's gonna be a [__] gpt4 now yeah
yeah I'll Emoji GPT one
you know then they started with gpd3 I
think it's just gpg yeah because I I
just I thought gpt3 they said it doesn't
say one two three it's I'm just using it
they just went to four immediately
that's how good it is I thought the one
we got to play with was gpt3 no am I
making [__] up I think I'm just [__]
around I think you're right you guys
don't use it I use it yeah I would use
it for for everything dude cause I'll be
like I'd be like what is a safe
investment and then they'll show up
right and then from there you can pick
and choose it's like instead of Google
what is a safe investment yeah but I
don't remember but as Chad GPT but like
it's you know like Google you got to put
in a prompt right or like a question and
then you got a [__] browse and click
but then with chai gbt it just [__]
just tells us housing and clickings for
you she made it sometimes at gbt it
Googles and picks one of those
it'll usually say [__] like this what I
don't [__] like is all the
disclaimers and things they have to put
in because America and legal [__] they
don't just cut to the chase so they'll
just say stuff like you know
um this is not Financial advice I don't
have whatever whatever they'll say all
that stuff and then they go but if you
would like to know and then I'll just be
like and then you can really uh make it
you could shrink it smaller and smaller
and smaller and being like um you know
what is the average like
um
I don't know like cap rate in Honolulu
so and then it'll just be like between
these years uh it was this this
percentage or whatever yeah well our boy
Elon uh has actually been one of a
thousand people to sign a letter to stop
the AI development immediately in order
to
um put an end to the risk of uh
Humanity's downfall I agree with them
dude you don't really like AI huh he's
he's come out a bunch saying like we
need to stop it no because he believes
in Singularity like he believes in like
robots taking over and [__] us up he
believes the best way to fix that is to
conjoin with uh AI technology versus
like having the separation between like
Humanity versus technology like we
become the AI cyborg yeah yeah Cyborg's
in essence I agree with that
[__] man that's more along the
lines of Ray kurzwell like he's um he's
like a modern and like like what do you
call it like a Tesla like yeah like yeah
is it Ray kurtzel he's an inventor or
like um he he's like an electronic
engineer inventor all that stuff but I
always knew him as the dude with the
gray kurzwill like keyboard synthesizer
like I I didn't know that he did all of
these things like [__] Da Vinci and
it not only did he invent [__] but he
also like prophesies stuff no [__] and
one of it was like we're on our way to
[__] AI all that [__] is happening
now he did this [__] like 15 20 years
ago wow what I'm scared of is the actual
like symbiosis of it because if we
already feel like there's a big gap
between the rich and the poor and the
Have and the have-nots now you give like
the upper echelon of people a super
processing computer and you get
[__] that are like
underprivileged that they're not going
to use it so now the billionaires will
turn into trillionaires the have-nots
will have more and then I mean the haves
will have more and the have-nots will
just be the same and they're just going
to be a huge Divine same as it ever was
my friend but even more so I say
download it into my [__] eyeballs put
it in my head load me up yeah remove my
brain and put it in my [__] head yeah
trying to be a cyborg well no the phone
right the phone already like I love my
[__] phone I love it more than my
wife and like so if you could get me
closer to the phone like you could put
the phone in my face like in my eyeball
dude like [__] sign me up yeah I'm
bored of it why can't I just like type
like this
don't type it again that's Joe on the
computer right now that's Joe watch the
documentaries we're talking to Joe he's
just like halfway through I'm still
learning more about fetal Japan yeah go
you look at Instagram he's like no and
that's a good example you give Steve a
phone look at how much he knows about
crypto you give someone else's phone
it's just nothing but booty on there you
don't know that's true we'll do what
they're gonna do yeah leave them alone
with it long enough so uh uh Elon uh
basically he um there was a letter that
was issued by the non-profit called
future of Life Institute that has over a
thousand ex experts must concluded and
just to note it's also predominantly
funded by the must foundation and the
founders pledge
um warning people of the alleged risk
that AI can pose for civilization
especially because during this time
there's this giant race now suddenly
everybody's like oh AI chat gbt all this
stuff there's like this huge almost like
viral social sensation about it so
people are trying to like race towards
some concept of AI they got all those
crazy ass pictures of [__] Trump and
[__] you got Kanye singing Drake songs
have you seen those ones no I've seen
the pope wearing like fresh ass gear
though I can't even distinguish what's
real and what's fake the hands bro yeah
the candy yeah
everyone's got like nine fingers and
[__] and it's all a long and alien like
all right the Pope's necklace only had
one side
it's like wait did the Pope's mom drink
wine while he was in her
maybe not the crazy thing are the all
those remote jobs how they all use them
now have you seen that really people
that work remotely they just use chat
gbt to do all their work yeah like
people who are in engineering or are uh
crazy people who write copy are the
biggest [__] yeah I use it on my
website if you write copy if you write
copy you basically have no job dude if
you're a legal admin you're about to get
[__] in the ass bro it's about to come
it's the dick is coming it's time to
lube up yeah legal stuff dude
yeah dude it's hard to lube all the way
ai's taking over you should start
drinking Lube too just to make sure
you're full so as your digestion it's
already there that's your best advice
listen yeah you could you could prompt
it to do Legal Zoom stuff yep you could
be like write a contract these are the
terms this and this and you don't need a
lunch break you don't need to pay it
give me a break I've seen people use a
chat gbt to write like code yeah you can
use the certain code yeah so I was like
dude what what just copy and paste it
kids using then for essays everything so
it's like it's very very useful actually
which is why this is genre it is used
for you again the letter warns that AI
systems with human competitive
intelligence can pose profound risks to
society and Humanity powerful AI systems
should be developed only once we are
confident that their effects will be
positive and their risks will be
manageable but I thought that chat gbt
doesn't actually think think what it
what it does is just goes through the
internet on blog post compiles
everything and then see what's yeah
what's commonly clicked and and then
they take those summer summaries and
words and puts it that's what I'm scared
of too because it's technically only
doing it based off of the person that
programmed it yeah you know what I mean
so the data it has available like on uh
the mesh was saying like it won't say
any jokes about black people right but
I'll tell you jokes about every other
race yeah
because someone so it's a white
programmer exactly so the AI thing is
going to be because it builds a Chinese
programmer you know they're going hard
on everybody
you know it's gonna get more and more
Consolidated by fewer people can be
manipulated yeah and it's like and the
whole thing will be in them these these
coders that were using it said that it
is wrong more than it is right when it's
down to code and they said that it's not
worth using because if if the code is
wrong they said it takes too long to
have to debug what Chad gbt gave you wow
so you might as well just do it yourself
they were saying that like the risk is
too high that if it's wrong then it's
it's too much work I was like oh that's
interesting but that's why I say like
legal [__] it's like you just gotta go
in there and proofread it real quick and
like
it out you got to send it to a paralegal
who's also using it dude start ordering
Lube from Costco like the big tubs
wholesale yeah the Big Tub just mix
Kirkland slide yeah yeah rub some on
yeah just get ready topical and adjust
it yeah man one of the measures included
advising a six-month halt to what has
been dubbed as the dangerous race in
developing systems even more powerful
than open ai's recently launched gpt4 so
they're basically saying stop it right
now like literally development for at
least six months like halt it as like
other developments are but people are
going to develop in secret what kind of
safeguards do we want on this thing it's
like a drug you know you know what's
crazy have you guys seen you guys watch
Westworld at all yeah there's um so
they're the newer season there's
something where like the AI kind of went
out of control and what happened was
they were able to use AI to determine
the worth of specific people so like
based on where you were born your
background your DNA and everything they
could tell how far you would get in life
and what you'd be capable of doing they
would just not allow you certain
accesses they would go oh you're pretty
much a janitor so they would just be
able to tell you based on AI like how
how well you would do as a person pretty
crazy right that sounds like what they
tried to do in communist countries when
they yeah determined your jobs or some
[__] is what people say all the time too
when I hear about you know people like
well you should just abort that kid
because like it's going to be a little
thief or something I'm like Jesus dude
all right that's like hey I said there's
no judging just it's like a gypsy baby I
say just let him aboard it but like why
you gotta be all like right now I know
right yeah we have to write that on the
chart yeah it's a weird dude
for that kid I say let them abort it but
yeah let them let them flush it
don't build the backstory about why it's
a [__] gonna be a super villain or
whatever
[Music]
foreign